[Music]
i've robbed 12 banks in seven states
i have a little over 9 million dollars
in cash
and no one knows who i am
federal bureau of investigation i want
to turn myself in
i want to make a deal what kind of deal
i hand over all the money i stole
in exchange for a reduced sentence it's
important
and what's so important about it i met a
woman
i want to be with her for the rest of my
life without lying about my past
[Music]
special agent hall this is special agent
evans where's the money
the man is telling the truth we can take
this money for ourselves
let's do it
whoa whoa i'm turning myself in fbi open
up
what
his real name is thomas dolan former
marine demolitions expert
he needs to come clean i'm not a bank
robber anymore but the murder one charge
for killing one of their own
feds will come after me and keep coming
those two crooked cops are willing to
kill another agent
what are they capable of doing to you
and me
[Music]
my girlfriend she had nothing to do with
this it's an evidence
i'm coming for you do what you have to
do
knowing how to blow stuff up that's
pretty cool
i want to clear my name which means i
need a full confession from you
five four
three two
one
ready to confess
[Music]
you